looking for the perfect Maine getaway
you won't find a better fit than dairy
the crown jewel of Penobscot County
located miles from the traffic flow
and the questionable animal control of
castleball life is a smile in dari
despite anything you may have heard a
little bit about dari is a town with a
rich living history that you'll feel as
soon as you pass City Limits whether
it's on a visit to our famous kissing
bridge the perfectly preserved house at
Twentynine niebolt Street or the
original campsite of the fur trappers
who first settled this land then
disappeared for clear easy to explain
reasons but with dairies history closing
in around you your cares will vanish
just like they did enjoy a quiet
laid-back town full of scenic views and
suction where the local children's still
play outside oh look at that ship
captain go
combine the boom there's for it you
might start seeing things rent a bike
and explore downtown head to the quarry
for some fun in the Sun of course the
biggest attraction in Derry is our
one-of-a-kind sewer system a complex
labyrinth of dark tunnels and chambers
that connects to every drain gutter and
pipe in town go ahead talk into any hole
you'll never guess who's on the other
side it's a blast to explore on your own
or with friends just make sure you've
escaped brick turns to shelter before
the 7:00 p.m. curfew it's mandatory
dairy is a small town with big ideas
that's been called the Paris of central
north eastern Maine catch one of the two
era defining films at our movie theater
compete in the world-famous Kitchener
Iron Works Easter egg hunt check out an
interactive book from the dairy Public
Library don't forget your free balloon
then put the kids to bed and dance until
dawn at the black spot the heart of
dairy's vibrant multi-ethnic
if you time your visit for the summer
Jerry's famous clowning in the park
series is as frightening as it is
unnecessary but if you miss it don't
worry the clowns of Derry will always
come before
but the spirit of dairy is defined by
its people whether it's helpful shop
keeps you look just like Lois Lane
local geology enthusiasts or just plain
honest folk with good old-fashioned
American Family Values
ain't nothing like a little sphere to
make a paper man crumble don't believe
me take it from a local derriere I love
this town Tara had its trouble 27 years
ago and 27 years before that and so on
but what city doesn't have a few issues
I have occasional visions of my family
drowning in rivers of blood but these
views are worth a pound of flesh
literally whether you're visiting for
the first time or returning to fulfill a
childhood blood oath it's all happening
right here in our little slice of
paradise so come on down to dairy town
and give us your fear your sweet sweet
fear
stay away from the underground lair of I
mean vacation give us your vacation
dairy where there's nothing to fear but